[Música]
zapatos pantalones vestidos y todo tipo
de prendas de vestir se pueden encontrar
en el desierto de atacama en el norte de
chile el lugar más seco del mundo que se
ha convertido en un vertedero y en un
verdadero cementerio de reposada
provenientes en su mayoría de eeuu
europa o asia chile es el mayor
importador de ropa usada de sudamérica
pero se calcula que las 59 mil toneladas
que entrega el año más de la mitad van a
parar a vertederos clandestinos además
de chile áfrica es el mayor vertedero de
nuestra basura electrónica más de 352
mil toneladas de residuos tóxicos salen
cada año de la unión europea hacia
países en desarrollo de áfrica europa
del este y también de asia todo un
verdadero problema nuestros residuos lo
que nosotros generamos para ello
entonces quiero saludar a nuestra
segunda invitada ella es el xynthia
menéndez coordinadora de ciudades
sustentables de ww 1 efe méxico gracias
cynthia por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 para word
para abordar esta triste realidad de
este problema
estamos nosotros pues echando nuestra
misma basura encima y no estamos
haciendo nada al respecto y le pregunto
entonces cuál es el problema real con
estos residuos de basura
hola muy buenos días pues muchísimas
gracias por el espacio pues la
invitación y efectivamente pues ya es un
problema que pues ya hablamos de una
crisis no el tamaño y la dimensión de
nuestra basura en general nuestros
residuos pues ya ha rebasado todos los
límites que debería deberíamos de haber
puesto desde hace muchos años y
realmente creo que el origen del
problema este es lo que deberíamos estar
poniendo atención porque estamos en una
economía lineal en donde todo lo que
producimos absolutamente todo la mayoría
acaba terminando como basura no y no
debería de ser así deberíamos encontrar
ese valor que tienen los residuos al
final de la vida útil de los diferentes
productos y reintegrarlos a nuestra
economía entonces creo que el problema
deberíamos de atacarlo de raíz porque
entonces no le damos un uso responsable
a todo el material que desechamos y que
se puede clark que está pasando porque
no hay acciones concretas sobre esto
pues son muchos muchos los puntos ahí no
en primera por supuesto pues la falta de
educación y de conocimiento de toda la
gente los usuarios finales la industria
en general también que puede tiene
muchos residuos que no solamente
hablamos de los residuos que generamos
en casa sino lo que se genera en la
industria y pues en todo el sector
económico de nuestra de nuestra sociedad
y entonces pues este es un primer punto
no de la falta de conocimiento la falta
de educación pero por supuesto también
la falta de regulación es una un gran
vacío que deberíamos estar atendiendo
para que exista la infraestructura
adecuada para que existan los modelos
adecuados y no sólo para fomentar el
reciclaje que como bien dices pues esto
puede ayudar de manera significativa de
reducir el problema sin embargo no lo
ataca de raíz no tendríamos que estar
pensando en cómo cambiar nuestros
modelos de producción y consumo para
evitar que se genere toda esa basura
por ejemplo no pongo un ejemplo muy muy
específico para que veamos cómo
podríamos estar hablando de una
transformación total de nuestros
nuestros modelos de consumo y producción
para que ya no estemos generando tanta
basura no es algo muy sencillo como algo
que hacíamos antes un par de
generaciones antes y es rellenar las
botellas que utilizamos no nos hemos
convertido en generadores de botellas de
plástico de un solo uso de una
dimensiones totalmente fuera de control
pues eso
botellas si esa iniciativa es muy
interesante que también se está haciendo
aquí en colombia y cada vez pues se
genera más conciencia no en rellenar
estas botellas diarias que consumimos
nosotros de plástico con también
residuos plásticos para que se pueda
reciclar absolutamente todo y también
darnos cuenta como lo hizo usted de todo
lo que consumimos y que absolutamente
todo es plástico todo es anger para el
medio ambiente y también crear nosotros
conciencia en ese orden de ideas que
daño ambiental estamos produciendo le a
nuestro planeta
bueno el daño es terrible simplemente
hablando del tema de plásticos y no no
hablando de los otros residuos que
también mencionaste que ahorita me
gustaría también tocar esos puntos pero
simplemente hablando del tema de
plásticos como bien sabemos pues hay una
gran fuga de the air y la generación de
plásticos a la contaminación por
plásticos que desgraciadamente la mayor
parte termina en el mar no creo que ya
muchos hemos escuchado esa cifra
aterradora de que si continuamos con esa
fuga de plásticos a nuestros cuerpos de
agua principalmente a nuestros mares o
sean los ríos pues habrá más peces
perdón habrá más plástico que peces para
el año 2050 y nuestros mares no es una
cifra aterradora
simplemente en el volumen de plástico
que se genera no vemos estas islas de
plástico en todos lados ya que antes
eran en algunas zonas focalizadas de
asia por ejemplo pero poco a poco
empezamos a ver eso también en
latinoamérica y pues es verdaderamente
aterrador no que esto estoy sucediendo
porque además tienen consecuencias
mayores no solamente
y obviamente a la biodiversidad marina
que vemos a las tortugas a los delfines
enredados y muriendo por causas del
plástico que llega a los mares sino
también que se generan micro plásticos
que afectan a la salud humana que
afectan a los ecosistemas y que por
supuesto tienen una consecuencia que aún
no alcanzamos a dimensionar
sitia tengo tres puntos importantes que
no quiero que se me queden por fuera
entonces le pido que por favor sea muy
breve para poder tocarlas en nuestra
conversación primero de esta basura
tecnológica que está pasando a dónde va
a parar y el daño que le causa si
justamente será el otro punto que quería
comentar no la basura tecnológica es una
de las más dañinas porque contamina y es
tóxica no entonces contamina no
solamente el sitio donde acaba de
dispuesta que generalmente son tiraderos
a cielo abierto y contamina también el
agua por la lixiviación de todos los
tóxicos no entonces la mayoría de los
desechos electrónicos no tomamos
conciencia y los desechamos junto con el
resto de la basura no entonces deberían
de tener una disposición adecuada y se
deberían de recuperar todos los
materiales no hay muchos metales
pues de difícil acceso que tienen un
proceso extractivo muy dañino para la
naturaleza y que finalmente acaban
también contaminando nuestra tierra
nuestra agua y todo porque no se
recuperan de la forma adecuada estamos
saliendo una pandemia que va a pasar
entonces con todos los residuos de la
pandemia que hoy 19 tapabocas guantes
batas los hisopos para hacer las pruebas
qué está pasando con eso sí también ese
es un gran problema que se ha
incrementado durante estos dos años de
forma alarmante y desgraciadamente en
muchos países no existe la regulación
para hacer la disposición adecuada de
estos residuos que además de obviamente
tienen que tratarse de forma especial
porque tienen un contenido peligroso no
que pues en este caso es el contenido
biológico entonces los deberíamos de
poner regulaciones mucho más estrictas
en este tema porque toda esa basura si
debería de ser incinerada y por supuesto
en sitios pues hechos adecuadamente para
eso para que no la contaminación después
se genere en otro sitio